Got anything in your pocket dude?
No. My phone and my wallet and my keys.
Take those out?
No.
Hello, the internet.
We are by a pool.
There is
Tad aa
What potential we have here now.
Try and do the happiest
belly flop you've ever done.
Like full on smiles the whole way down.
Well, it's gonna be a side flop.
A side flop, yeah, a side flop.
This is not natural. Okay. Ready?
Yeah
Oh God!
So now Dan's going to
fall directly backwards
inception style into the water.
Trying not to wind myself, die
or hit the bottom of the pool.
Or get electrocuted, hey?
Hey, yeah.
Ow!
Ah yeah. Ah people.
You get winded?
Oh God no. Breathed out, but oh God.
What happens if you breathe in?
If I'd have a lung full of air
I'd probably be at the
bottom of the pool somewhere.
Is my back red?
No it's hairy though.
Oh, cheers, yeah, great.
I knew that already.
Right you've done a few, a few jumps.
What you gonna do now?
Gonna do a sexy sort of whale shape thing.
Come out the water, like
a whale, but a sexy whale.
A sexy whale.
If that's possible, it's going to be
five, four, three, two, bang.
Okay.
Well, that looked pretty lush.
My favorite one is the one
of you just back dropping.
That's not my favorite.
My back really hurts.
That's absolutely kills.
It's really interesting how the water
at certain speeds just
it's like a shell over you.
Especially when you were leaping out.
Yeah, it's cool.
Water just looks cool.
I can really just have a
high speed camera and a pool
and just be happy and retire.
It actually took quite
a lot of concentration
to maintain those faces and like poses
into the water, quite difficult.
Why didn't you go in?
Well, I had to film it, didn't I?
So it's nothing to do with being cold or
Nah, would you want to to film it?
Not really into it to be fair?
Not really your thing?
No.
That's exactly what it's like. Yeah.
Follow us on Twitter. Subscribe.
Thanks for watching. Dan's in a huff.
Dan!